- Are you a young graduate
who is applying for the first job?
Are you a young professional
who is looking to transition careers?
Surely,
one thing that would be
very important to succeed
is a strong CV.
When I applied to the
consulting firm McKinsey,
back in the days
I faced the same challenge.
So in this video,
I wanna share some of my
knowledge by reviewing your CVs.
So a couple of days ago on my Instagram,
I asked you to submit some CVs to me,
for me to potentially review them.
If you want to have your CV included
in potential future videos like this,
follow me on Instagram.
This is where I most likely
will talk about this again.
Before we start diving into the CVs,
a couple of preliminary remarks,
first of all,
all of these things are of
course just my humble opinions,
my humble experiences,
surely the topic of how
a strong CV looks like
is a topic
where many people have
many differing opinions on,
but feel free to challenge
me also in the comments.
If you have another view
on any of the points that I'm raising.
So welcome to another coffee
break here on my channel,
Firm Learning,
my name is Heinrich
and on my channel I want to help you
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
In addition,
also for both the CV and
a cover letter template
for you as a download,
these were the very same
templates that I used myself,
when I successfully applied
to the consulting firm,
McKinsey, back in the days.
You'll find a link to them
in the video description,
so feel free to check them out.
So let's start looking
at this first CV here
and let just go by a
very first impression.
So just looking at this,
how does this seem?
Does this seem professional
and good or not?
And I'd say this is not very bad.
I mean, it's not, not terrible,
but there's surely some
things that you could improve.
So let's look just at a couple of things
that I think are not really on point,
not really ideal here.
And for us, let's start
with some alignment points.
I'm just zooming in here.
Let's go up here.
We see that here that all kind
of different levels are used
when things start, right?
So here you have a level of text
where this level, it starts,
this here is a bit dented
further to the right.
This line here is even a bit
further left than this stuff.
This here is even further left.
So you see all different
types of layout levels.
So where elements start.
All right, next,
let's talk a bit more about the content,
for instance about an
introductory text like this.
It's actually many CVs that I received,
I saw people including
a little intro text here
in the beginning,
and here, I'm not saying
this is a deal breaker.
How this alone we get you rejected,
but let's just try to put ourselves
into the shoes of a person who reads CV's.
You will have big stack of CV's,
a big stack of paper on your desk.
You would just go one after the other.
We try to skim the CV for some keywords,
for the key things that you did.
Where did you work?
Where did you study?
What are your grades?
What are your responsibilities?
I would argue that these people
really not even care to bother,
to start reading a big
paragraph of text like this.
So Max is a strategy
and consulting manager,
and he's aligned to the company,
Capital Markets Practice.
He has a professional understanding
of the financial sector,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I mean,
these are things that
we would directly see
if you read it right
here, senior consultant.
What did you do?
Security settlement.
Okay. Got it.
Right.
So no need for any explanations like this.
Next, let's talk about a
picture here in the top, right?
This is also a question
that I get quite frequently.
So are you supposed to include
a picture in the CV or not?
And here I'd say it really depends
probably most on the
region where you apply to.
So I'd argue more on the
Anglosaxon countries,
so UK also the US and so on,
I'd say it's rather
unusual to include it for,
of course, discrimination reasons.
You don't want CVs to be assessed
based on the looks of
a person, for instance.
in countries like Germany,
I would claim that it is
still very common to have a
picture on your CV.
So probably I would also still do it
in a country like Germany,
though, if you apply, for instance,
via are online form,
often that online forms
have specific fields
where you can upload a picture.
So if you did already upload
a picture to such a form,
then I'd say you also don't
need the picture on the CV.
Personally,
on my standard CV, don't have
a picture included of course,
with the nice one page format
that I would recommend
you to use in general,
a picture takes a lot of space.
Often doesn't integrate
that nicely in the layout.
So if you can,
I'll probably try to get
away with not including it
on the CV,
but in some reasons it's
truly not a problem.
Next, let's talk about,
there's a very general
layout here of the CV
where you have here the key
content side on the left,
and then this additional
bar here on the right
and actually several CVs that you sent me
had variations of this layout.
In my humble perspective on is
that I would probably rather
not go for these layouts.
So surely if you apply
to a marketing agency
or maybe another very creative job, sure.
Be creative, do some fancy,
maybe also build an
Orthodox stuff on your CV,
I trust there it's okay.
But especially if you apply to
more conservative industries
like consulting or like banking,
surely you will not get
invited to an interview
because of the way how
you lay outed your CV.
This is just not the way
of thinking about this.
The best case scenario is
the people who just not care
that use the layout like this.
But of course the worst case scenarios
that this will rub people the wrong way,
people might feel like,
ah, maybe you didn't do your research.
You didn't know how a typical CV layout
for these industries look like.
And surely
this is not the impression
that you want to leave.
And I'd argue also from
a functional perspective,
layouts like this are not very effective.
Let's just see how much
space is wasted here
with the personal info.
The personal info you can usually include
just in one line in the very
head of your one page CV.
You will later see a
couple of other examples
of people did that.
And same thing here for the languages.
I mean, this takes so much space.
You can just write this in one simple line
and let's not even get me started here
on all these dots to indicate
your language proficiency.
Because indeed what we do see
is that actually the font size
here of the volume of the CV
is very small.
This is a very small font size.
And yes,
I gather that on one page of CVs,
often you have lots of texts
and often the font size
cannot be too large,
but this is very small, right?
And you would have all
these other opportunities
to make more space for the text,
increase the font size.
And also in general,
at least in the body of your CV,
I would recommend you to
always use the same font size.
It always looks a bit unclean,
not very polished
if you have fewer texts
with a larger font size,
then here, it gets smaller,
this is larger again,
it doesn't just look very clean,
very polished.
So rather go for the same
font size whenever possible.
Let's move to the second CV.
And by the way,
I will try all the different CVs
to highlight different things, right?
So only cause I don't point out again,
the things that I maybe
pointed out on prior CV,
of course, they're still
very much all true,
but let's just continue here.
And very first impression,
again, maybe think about
this for yourself, right?
What is the very first
impression that you have?
And I'd say it's rather good.
I like it.
I think it's very clear,
very well organized.
The layout seems nice
and clean and principal,
I like it here.
Here we also see some of these
a bit more modern layout elements,
like these icons here to
indicate your address,
the phone and so on,
this blue border around your picture,
this light gray or these blue bars here
to indicate a new subsection.
I mean, I don't know.
So surely this won't get you rejected,
personally I also think it looks good.
Here's still probably myself,
if I would write a CV for me,
I would still go for the
very conservative style
without all these things included.
The thing that probably bothers me most
is just the length.
And this is just a lot of
content, two full pages.
And let's also not forget
that this person is still a student.
And I know that the general rule is
that up to two pages is okay.
I think more than two pages is really bad.
You should not do it,
but I would still
recommend you to go for the
one pager layout.
Every single CV out there
you can condense to one pager layout.
Even if you have 30, 40
years of work experience,
it's always possible to
bring it to one page.
Of course, what this means
is that you need to focus.
You maybe need to cut out some things
which are not the strongest
things you want to talk about,
or really reduce them to a minimum.
But trust that everybody already
was in the position to review CVs.
It's almost much nicer to have one page
just instead of always
needing to go back and forth
across different pages.
And also one page in general
helps you much more to really
focus on your awesomeness.
So ideally the impression
that you want to create
is that someone reads your CV
and every single line, right?
Every single line just reads.
Wow, this is crazy.
Impressive, impressive, awesome.
Never seen this.
This is incredible.
But if you drag out the
content over two pages,
usually you don't have enough
things to really fill it
with that much awesomeness.
Then the awesome points,
really just get lost,
the more mediocre points.
And this is just not the first impression
that you want to give.
So let's just look at that.
What are the things that maybe
you would want to cut out?
Maybe you don't want
to focus on that much.
And here, if you read it surely
the big household names like
BMW, Allanson and so on,
these surely are the things
you do wanna focus on,
but then you also read
things like Neurodynamics,
ABCA strategy consultants and so on.
And if as a student,
you already have these
very strong internships
at BMW, Allanson and so on.
You think someone will really care
that you've worked at Neurodynamics
or CA Strategy Consultants.
And again,
don't want to come off
here as condescending.
I just don't know these firms.
Maybe these are very great firms,
some hidden champions in a very niche,
but I'd argue the general HR content
will just not know them.
And just also one thing to understand is
that you don't need to list
every single work experience,
every single internship
that you ever completed
throughout your life.
So probably at the point
when I applied to McKinsey
at the end of my bachelor,
likely half of the internships I ever did,
I didn't even list anymore on my CV
because I just replaced
them by stronger points,
by stronger stations at the point in time.
And the other thing that I
always find a little bit weird
when I read this,
especially on a student CV
are things like being
an external consultant,
of course, this is always
a little bit weird,
but you're a student,
why would a big company engage you
as an external consultant?
What type of experience was that?
So this always leaves some question marks.
If then you scroll down,
I think the explanation is
that this person worked
at Academy Consult.
I just happen to know that organization
because they're from Munich,
they're a student based consulting firm.
So this of course great,
great and relevant experience,
but then maybe just to
condense it a little bit,
you might be able to take
these external consulting positions
and then rather list them here,
for instance, within the
Academy Consult position,
just to make this a
little bit more intuitive
how exactly that went,
and this will help you to save some space
and also help the reader of the CV,
just in a more intuitive way understand
what exactly happened there.
What exactly did you do here.
Following the idea of saving space.
Also things like language skills,
computer skills, hobbies,
these are things that
you can just very shortly
write in one line.
If you're looking for
some inspiration on that
in the CV template that I
will offer you as a download
in the video description,
you can see exactly how I did it in there.
And then there's also
this thing here in the end
with the location,
the date and the signature,
I know that many people tell you
that you need to include it.
At least in Germany,
it's very customary to do so,
to be honest in all the
applications that I wrote,
I never included it.
I always didn't see the
point of doing that.
It always felt like a
waste of space to me.
I would rather maybe sign the cover letter
if you wanna sign something.
So judge this for yourself,
whether you wanna include it or not.
For me, it was never a
problem to leave it out.
But I do know that some people feel like
it needs to be included on every CV.
So trust you will decide
what's right for you.
As the last point,
let's talk about the
bullets that you write.
And we went on a later CV,
probably talk a little bit more
about how to write bullets,
but just the one thing I
wanna point your attention to
what I would in general always avoid
is writing things like
supporting something.
This sounds very weak, right?
It's really difficult to understand
what you really did there,
what your impact was,
what your contribution was.
Also things like developing of market
and business fields
strategies here on top.
I mean, these things are so vague.
They really fail to highlight
what your experiences really are,
what the impact was that you
created for the organization.
But let's deep dive into
considerations like this
a bit more in the future.
So let's look at the next CV
and here again, first impression.
What do we think about this?
I think what's very clear,
just for a side that
this CV is far too long.
I mean, this is frankly just unacceptable.
You cannot make a CV with six pages.
Two pages should be the absolute maximum.
I would recommend you to
only work with one page,
but six pages in just not okay.
So let's just see what
this person did here.
First of all, let's look at the alignment.
I mean, here again,
the bullet starts to the
right then further down,
it starts here to the left.
And then if we go down,
we see things like this, for instance,
where then suddenly something
starts further to the right.
I mean, this is surely not, okay.
This is not what I would
recommend you to do.
Then some other small sloppy
things in the formatting
let's notice how here
this longer dash is used.
I believe it's called an EM dash,
whereas here a shorter dash,
an EM dash as I believe
it's called, is used.
These are just sloppy,
small things in the formatting
that of course should to rather avoid.
Next let's talk about the
professionally experience
and here first let's talk also about
the order of the sections.
So I'd say the general recommended way
is that as long as you're are a student,
you start your CV after
the personal details,
with the education section,
because surely this is the
focus for you as a student.
But as soon as you are a professional,
working professional who
moves out of university,
I'd say it's customary then to move up
the professional experience section,
and then only afterwards
show the education section
because surely this will usually be
what will be more relevant
to the person reading the CV.
What you should definitely avoid
is writing about these experiences,
like you would write
a paragraph in a book.
So just full sentences,
full paragraph of text.
It's just really difficult,
just to quickly read over this,
skim through it.
And just in a straightforward way,
get the most important pieces
of information out of it.
It really forces the people
to read through all of this
and this in combined with the
fact that the CV in itself
is already so long.
It's just so annoying,
just such a hassle for the
person looking at that.
I promise you the people will get annoyed
that will need to read this.
Also the formatting,
this of course is just not really nice.
You know,
having a page break in the
middle of such a position,
let's further move down here.
We now see all the courses
that this person completed.
I mean,
it's surely great that the
person did that many things.
I mean, frankly not sure
what all of this is.
This looks like university courses.
Surely you don't need
to list all the courses
that you attended at
university on your CV.
This just creates the impression
that you're not able to distinguish
the things that really matter
from the things that maybe
don't matter that much.
So again,
same thing here with the awards
and the same with also
published materials.
So as long as you apply
for an academic job,
I'd argue your publication list
does not need to be part of the CV.
If you want included,
I would rather,
maybe in your awards and honor section
or your other qualification section,
I just include one line
and really just highlight
the key achievements here.
Maybe that you publish
an article in an A plus
or in an A journal, right?
Things like that surely are impressive,
but Hey, come on. I mean,
let's not write about newspaper articles
that you wrote or your
undergraduate thesis.
This is surely not what,
what should be relevant
to you for your CV.
So enough about that,
let's move to the next CV.
So what I like is that it
is on a one pager format,
but I think the first impression
just without really looking at it,
the first impression is that
somehow this looks a little bit messy
and a bit unusual, right?
So let's just look into that.
What do we see here?
I mean, first of all,
just the top section,
I'd argue that you can
include your personal details
in an even more space effective
way as has been done here.
Again, feel free to
check out the CV template
that I offer you as a download
in the video description.
Also things like a LinkedIn profile,
I'd say it's not really needed.
I mean, surely all the info
that you have on your LinkedIn,
you will likely also have in here,
also this very dark black
bar I see at the top.
I mean, this looks just very dominant,
this dark black, just a bit unusual,
also not something that I would include
and also summary sentences
like this here on top,
we already discussed for the first CV.
So let's continue looking at this.
And one thing that comes to mind
is that even though this is a one pager,
there's still lots of wide space.
So the impression that the summer creates
is that even though you only had one page,
you were not even able
to fill all this page
with good and relevant content.
And then if you continue looking at that,
you can see that here
just from the language and skills section,
this takes almost half of the page.
I mean,
this is a section
that probably just in
a very small section,
the bottom you would talk about.
So for instance,
the section that I will
flesh out much more
is the academic education section.
So for instance,
what are your majors,
what are the main subjects
that you're focusing on?
What is your GPA?
What are maybe some other
academic leadership positions
that you have,
so surely these are things I talk about
and I'd say here in the work experience,
there are a couple of things in here
which are a little bit weird.
I mean, what are these numbers here?
Two and one, I'm just
not really getting it.
Also here the formatting of these bullets.
It's a little bit weird here.
I mean,
this should truly be indented here
also to the level of the right
and lets just come back to the point of,
of how you write bullets.
So as I already hinted before,
I would always stress on the impact
and the results that you
created for the company.
So instead of writing
automation of process
with efficiency gains and risk reduction,
I would rather always try
to quantify it, right.
So how did you implement
these efficiency gains,
to what measurable results
did this really yield for the company?
The key basic idea is
that whenever possible,
whenever it makes sense,
you should include the number
in the bullets of your CV,
just to make them tangible,
make them grasp the...
Help everyone understand
the impact that you had.
What I do like is what the
person wrote here below
with the volunteer coordinator.
So talking about coordinating
a team of 40 volunteers
on a project,
I think this is great,
really talking about the
leadership that you had,
how large the team was that you led,
of course here,
it would've been great
to also focus a bit more
again, on the impact that
you had in your volunteering.
So what was the good that you
created for your community,
for the organization here?
Talk about that as well,
because surely that was your goal
for volunteering after all.
Last but not least let's look at one more.
And again,
let's start with first impression here
and I'd argue that likely this for me,
gives this strongest first impression.
This is most closely to the layout
that usually you can expect
when applying to consulting,
to banking,
to more conservative
professional services,
industries like that.
So what I can see here is a
nice and clean one pager CV.
You see how the name
and the personal details
really only takes minimal
space in the header of the CV.
This is the classic way of doing it.
Here this logo to the left,
I not really understanding
what exactly that is.
Looks like maybe the
logo of the university,
again, maybe I'm just
not getting the meaning.
I'd say probably not something
that you need to include,
but I'd say the overall layout,
the structure of the CV
is very good and clean.
So you start with education,
professional experiences,
leadership and awards,
volunteer experience.
Very good,
very clear,
very well done.
The one thing that maybe
is a little bit unorthodox
just with these a bit more
like modern design elements
are these points that were included here,
but why not?
I mean, again, surely
this won't be a problem.
One little, I guess error is here.
The spacing between the points, right?
So here, apparently a space is missing.
Whereas here we have spaces,
here again, the space is missing,
here again a spaces missing,
similar, I think here
also with the dashes.
So here there are spaces
between the dashes,
here there are no spaces
between the dashes.
Here, again inconsistencies
with the EM and EN dashes.
So the longer and the shorter dash,
again, maybe I'm just too super
critical about these things,
but these are things when I look at CVs,
for whatever reason, they
just directly jump in my eye.
I just cannot help but
notice these things.
And of course the underlying reasoning,
why these things maybe do matter is that
if you work for instance
in professional services,
you create documents for your clients.
You will for sure get feedback
on points like this, right?
So if in your client documents,
you just mess up only these
small layout inconsistencies.
I mean,
these are things that
you will get feedback on
from a project lead, for
your team lead and so on.
And of course the logic is that,
you know, this is your CV.
So this is a document where you
surely invested lots of time
to really get it right
to the smallest amount of detail, right?
I mean, the impression of course,
that this creates is that maybe you lack
the attention of detail
and if you cannot even
get such a document right,
how are you expected to
get these things right
if it's already, you know, late at night,
you are under lots of pressure
in a short amount of time.
You need to create a
significant amount of documents.
I mean,
this is just the reasoning
that an HR professional
might have in his or her head
when just looking at things like that
and then making comments on that.
But overall,
I must say I do like it,
also notice to here how
the bullets are written,
for instance,
this person rights increased
acetic acid product sales
by 50% by revitalizing
distributor portfolio
and adding to customer
base and so on, so forth.
So you really focus on the impact here.
Here also the next one
contributed towards annual
saving of over 80,000 Euro
written something that
reduced OPEX cost by 12%
saving 50,000 Euro and so on and so forth.
So really always pushing
for the measurable impact.
This is the style that you want to go for.
Just my little other layout style is,
I mean, first of all,
I really this idea of
bolding things like that,
I think this really helps guide the eye
to the most important words,
to the things that you
really wanna focus on.
But then I would argue if you do this,
try to have then one bolded thing
in all of the bullet points.
So for instance,
here is also actually
quite big bullet point
without any bolded elements.
Here I would also argue
that I think two lines
of text for one bullet
usually are enough.
So rather condense a bullet of three lines
a bit further to two lines.
This just looks a little bit cleaner.
Also,
if then all the other
bullets are two lines
as we have it here
than if you have suddenly
a bullet of three lines,
the somewhat sticks out,
probably not really necessary,
rather cut it down.
And then of course,
if you do have a nice CV like
that with all this content,
probably what I would think about
whether that you wouldn't want to give
a little bit more space to
the volunteering experience.
I mean,
this can be a little nice
additional touch on what you did
makes you seem to be a bit
more of a rounded character,
right?
Not a person just lives for a CV,
not only a person lives
for his or her education,
GPA and work experience.
If you were writing for social causes,
I trust you raised money maybe, right.
For social cause.
So why don't talk about that?
How much money you raised,
what your leadership position was
and bringing this to life,
making sure that this
happened last but not least,
just because we haven't talked
about it in that much detail,
I'd argue probably most
regions it's very customary.
So in your education section,
when you talk about your degrees,
that you'll also include your GPA.
Again,
I understand that university
systems are a bit different,
but if you received any
type of numeric GPA,
I would recommend you to
also included here on the CV.
Sometimes people ask me when
my GPA wasn't that strong,
should I still include it?
Even if it wasn't that strong?
And I'd say yes, because at least myself,
usually whenever I see a CV without GPA,
I just assume that the person
doesn't have such a great GPA,
right?
Because otherwise the person
would show it on the CV.
And then it's always just an annoyance
to needing to look at the
university transcripts
maybe that the person
hopefully then attached,
just look through all the
documents to pull out the GPAs
that the person actually has,
this is just annoying,
a waste of time,
be transparent, include them.
And of course, ideally
what always also helps.
And you probably,
I would only include it if
really these numbers are good,
but if you have a good
also percentage rank.
So if you can show that you
are part of the top five,
top 10, maybe top 15% of your class,
I would surely include this
year in the CV as well.
Because of course,
this helps also the HR professional,
just to understand and contextualize
the GPA a little better,
especially maybe if you're
applying for university,
maybe isn't one of the big target schools
where it's a bit less clear
on what the GPA really means,
whether this is a good reside or not.
So do you have any
additional tips to share
on how to write a strong CV?
So just leave a comment in
the comment section to us,
you will all benefit from that.
If you took any value
out of this video at all
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also hit subscribe and
turn on the notification bell
to stay up to date on all my content.
Thank you to the members of Firm Learning
for supporting the channel.
This is very much appreciated.
My name is Heinrich
I make these videos every
single weekend on Saturdays.
See you again next week
until then all the best
to you, and bye bye.